[Musique]
alors merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le premier débat
entre trump hebeisen à quoi doit-on
s'attendre qui a le plus à perdre selon
vous qu'on puisse s'attendre à quelque
chose de précis la situation est
imprévisible
donald trump est un batelier et on peut
s'attendre à voir un grand numéro ce
soir et on pourrait s'attendre ce conte
en est ce que ce débat se contente de
d'introduire les débats précédents on ne
peut pas vraiment savoir s'il s'agirait
vraiment d'une véritable discussion
quant à l'avenir du des états unis alors
justement après les dernières
révélations par le new york times sur
les 750 euros d'impôts payés par le
président américain en 2016 et 2017
joe biden vient de publié il ya quelques
heures ces dernières feuilles d'impôts
le 2 l at il déjà commencé finalement le
problème des impôts suis tonale 30
depuis le tout début de sa campagne et
même depuis le tout début de son mandat
donc ces soutiens sont des soutiens et
beaucoup d'histoires fracassantes sur
l'administration trump beaucoup de
surprises et beaucoup de surprises
interviennent souvent à proximité de
l'élection mais les soutiens de donald
trump le croise tout simplement pas à
ces histoires pense qu'il s'agit d'un
battage médiatique
ils se sont écartés des faits des
preuves en saveurs ton sorte de
partisanisme aveugle alors quelle est
l'ambiance aux états unis comme on les
différents médias décrypte cet événement
l'ambiance est très tendue il ya déjà
beaucoup de problèmes la couv it is 9
fait toujours rage
il ya des problèmes
les conflits entre races il y a
également un gros problème avec la
police
donc c'est tout un tas de sujets qui
s'ajoute aux problèmes économiques et
aux questions sur le confinement et la
fin éventuelle de confinement je pense
que l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir
des élections légitimes et d'avoir un
résultat aussi claire que possible afin
que le pays puisse continuer avec le
dirigeant quel qu'il soit alors quel
électorat
les deux hommes devront aller chercher
ce soit on sait que joe biden veut
reconquérir les ouvriers blancs par
exemple élection n'est pas une élection
à propos des parties il s'agit de
galvaniser les gens qui n'ont pas voté
aux dernières élections
l'administration obama a fait voter des
gens qui n'avaient jamais voté ou qui
avait arrêté de voter un débat ne permet
pas de changer d'avis et à peine plus
d'une heure une heure quarante-cinq cela
ne suffit pas pour changer sa vision du
monde
les électeurs ont déjà un candidat qui
les intéresse plus et de plus le
meilleur orateur n'est peut-être pas le
meilleur dirigeant
donc il ne faut pas penser que celui qui
remporte le débat devrait remporter les
élections
l'initiation n'a pas encore publié de
programmes pour la réélection alors que
les démocrates ont présenté un programme
très solide partie écrite et une partie
orale les démocrates protège obamacare
alors que l'administration de trump
essaye de s'en débarrasser c'est ce
genre de facteurs qui permet aux gens de
décider
et je ne pense pas que le débat de ce
soir va changer la donne sauf dans le
cas dans la mesure où cela va donner
plus d'élan à un des candidats mais à
part cela ça ne va pas changer la
dynamique politique du pays pour
conclure en quelques mots les
manifestations violentes se multiplient
aux etats-unis à qui profites t'elle en
vue des élections selon vous c'est une
question assez complexe mais je pense
que cela profite aux démocrates parce
que c est laisser ces manifestations
arrivent alors que donald trump est au
pouvoir et donald trump voudrait bien
recevoir un prix nobel de la paix alors
qu'il n'a même pas la paix dans son
propre pays est un problème
merci beaucoup à l'est nord d'avoir
répondu à deux questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat à stanford aux états
unis et